[Music]
will you tell people that I run a slot
car they got a what what's that I've
never heard of that before when they
first do it they go wow
this is fun I am buzzed Frank Perry I am
the proprietor of buzzer AMA the slot
car racing center of the world slot car
racing
he's a hobby sport that's participated
in all over the world in 1965 it was my
hobby I was one of the first to open in
New York there was 48 places like this
in the city today I'm it I'm the lone
survivor
I have 12 volt DC motors in them and a
guide flag that fits in slot and when
you hint the hand controller it
energizes those lanes and gives the
motor juice the faces cause can't go
upwards of 100 miles an hour so they're
like blurs now you have to hear them
your wing wing' can you see them you
have to listen to them you go Wow
kids play with computer now and there's
no interaction with anything over here
they have interaction with other drivers
they compete they congratulate each
other you learn sportsmanship is really
great just watching the cars go around
the tracks pumps up your adrenaline and
you get all excited and that that thrill
never leaves you you always think about
[Music]